des comparaisons suède france il faut
faire vraiment attention à ce qu'on dit
dessus il est comme on l'expliqué
plusieurs fois notamment le flao ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
différences au niveau de la mentalité
des gens la façon qu'ils ont de
respecter la loi ou de respecter des
recommandations le système économique
est différent le système de santé
différent la porte
la densité de population est très
différente à par stockholm la suède est
quasiment vide faut savoir que paris
plus enfin l'île de france c'est la
population d'asuel voilà sur un pays qui
est à peu près aussi grand que la france
donc c'est des choses qu'il faut réussir
à prendre en compte
à canton congrès c'est comparer ces deux
pays là et qu'on a tendance souvent
oubliée canton pour les comparaisons que
font les gens avec la suède quand ils
sont en france il ya quand même eu des
mesures restrictives en suède il ya
quand même eu des gens qui ont perdu
leur emploi il ya quand même eu des
problèmes économiques et malgré tout il
ya un bilan bien pire que tous les
voisins qui eux partait avec les mêmes
conditions que les suédois quasiment
fort couleurs on peut plus facilement
comparer le danemark et la suède qu'on
peut comparer la suède et la france et
le danemark sentir mieux au terme de
morts par million en termes de morts
cumulée et économiquement au moins aussi
bien donc pour le moment c'est pas très
joyeux
oui
[Musique]